okay i think we already started um but i
have a guitar
it's in my hands right here welcome to
the cast yeah welcome
[Music]
welcome back to the quarter cast
everybody it's episode 127.
um
yeah it's going to be a good one we got
jordan allen here today we got nick
laurent
we got ren wykman
and of course uh me jake watson so um
welcome back everybody how are you how
are you guys doing oh good you're doing
pretty good
chilling hey
you know this episode i think we're
going to have a lot of fun we're going
to talk about a lot of fluffy light
topics because last episode we had a lot
of hot takes flying around and people
got some very controversial topics and
opinions and
you know what it it's always you knew
you knew that's coming though oh of
course
you can't talk about anything hot
without getting hot takes back you know
that's just how it is you know once you
get me started i just i can't stop you
invited that in and i think but i do
think that in the future we should
completely
avoid talking about manchester by the
sea
um okay
we should never i'm serious like it's
just too controversial that's fair it
divides people instantly
yeah okay that's the best movie ever
made wren i swear to god
i swear to god i've never seen it isn't
that the casey affleck movie who
nobody knew that i just i wish i had not
said anything so we just assumed we just
assumed that everyone felt the same way
about it but apparently there are some
believers out there hey you know what
that's fake news
you know interesting tidbit about that
movie we had a chance to meet one of the
producers no way um yeah um his name was
chris uh really really nice guy um
you know when i went to uh
park city with carmichael yeah like
years ago
to do it oh yeah
yeah that he was on the panel that i was
on um and and he
yeah he uh
he he like specializes in like
basically like
well how to finance like
but usually with product placement
um like features
um so he helped finance manchester by
the sea and then he also actually helped
uh get um goodwill hunting
off the ground too yeah he he yeah he's
done quite a quite a few things
[Laughter]
one specifically has product placement
in it i don't think so i think we're
doing our own clam holes here
that one was financed by like an
individual you know
risk taker yeah
um but yeah he came by the studio we
wanted him to finance one of our ideas
but uh i was too happy
yeah i think they were too happy you
know they didn't have enough of a
single look just kind of staring off
we can't go two minutes into a
conversation without [ __ ] on
manchester united here we go
i didn't even realize i did i'd done it
you done did it
um but we do know that uh that shift is
going to be a hit so you know alright
yeah yeah
yeah i came up with a great idea
it's shift yeah it's an it's an indie
piece where tom cruise
goes down to 90 pounds oh nice nice to
prove how good of an actor he is telling
you how good of an actor he is not you
got to see it yeah
it's going to be and it's just it's just
about him being a normal mechanic with
like some some marital and family
problems
um and and that's it nothing actually
changes just like manchester by the sea
the character there's no characters
[Laughter]
working on oh man i spent half the day
composing an email
oh oh that was fun yeah like uh taxes
very effective use of reds time yeah it
wasn't actually half a day but it
mentally felt like it it's a very
important email i'm not going to say who
it's too
are you just being very particular with
your choices
you can't just it's it's a it's a vfx
artist react guest
high profile high profile not just any
guest
is one of the whale guests
yeah it's it's literally like the guest
that's been at the top of our list since
the beginning except for jackie chan
sorry it's not jackie chan yeah he's not
a vfx artist i know we don't know that
you know
i believe in him anyway yeah so that's
where my mind's at right now a lot of uh
reflection about the show and
us
and oh it's beautiful in him
reflection
yeah
what have you learned in your uh
introspection
that we're awesome
no
i don't really have any conclusions on
that front it's just like i don't know
it it's
it's easy to take for granted how cool
our job is like yeah dude
like we've been doing this for 10 oh i
mean
dude i just realized
like a week ago was my 10-year
anniversary at corridor no way
i totally forgot about that slap hands
i was just thinking it's like you know
we got our start you know making like
short films and whatnot and to try to
help
not supplement that but like we were
always very open and shared our process
and what we've learned along the way and
so from the beginning our philosophy has
always been open sharing of
you know knowledge and i think that's
it's very cool and
just like how we've evolved over the
years and
you know now we have this show that's
coming up on three years now which is
nuts three years people react and it's
and it's literally us just
sitting on a couch looking at stuff and
making faces
superficially that's what it's about
but it's like you know it's the the
educational side of things this i i'm
very passionate about that and it's cool
that we've been able to find an audience
who
this resonates with you know it's just
oh dude did you see uh very much
homeboy's uh breakdown of uh the show i
did
let me shout that out here because that
was a really good video yeah it was it
was straight up a video essay about
the the react show but also i think it
was more about the show than the quarter
crew channel i think yeah but he touches
on like the history of the channel and
like who we are and what we do and stuff
like that but it was more just kind of
an analysis breakdown
we can put a link in the description
here but it's by this guy doddford
d-o-d-f-o-r-d
um and because he's english because he's
english he
naturally sounds smarter
um yeah so people are smarter there's
immediately more credibility to what
he's saying they spoke english before we
did okay very smart exactly
it's called
it's called how chord or crew perfected
the reaction genre
um and it's an interesting uh
sort of
because it's an entertainment breakdown
because it really reflects a lot of our
own sort of like mentalities surrounding
the show because it's on the surface
it's about us just like
having a good time hanging out with your
friends joshing on some vfx being like
oh my god that's so great and and
whatnot but really it's an opportunity
for us to kind of just help educate the
general public about
things that they
wouldn't naturally understand because
they don't come across like most people
are not vfx artists but most people
watch movies and so most people have
this sort of shared experience of seeing
movies and effects and stuff like that
without any sort of insight about how
they're made
and and so like yeah our show is
it's about having a good time but also
just kind of illuminating
the
sort of
the movie magic you know it's cool yeah
it's a good video
yeah um
no that's awesome and i i really hope uh
we can continue to expand some of the
guests and
just continue to
to share that knowledge and that that
trademark and that i don't know i guess
the craftsmanship that goes into not
only like
what we're looking at and the way that
those things are made but also the show
itself our show
um
yeah
it's just a really really cool thing
and uh yeah we just shot today we shot
day one of punch for punch am i allowed
to talk about this
yeah we can talk about it i can say the
name of it dude yeah tell me about your
punch what is it let me context let me
yeah
do you want to contextualize it
you go for it and then i'll tell you
about the shoot
okay so um
there'll be more about this coming out
sort of as we get into it but
uh last year
um
netflix
uh
you netflix has a department that runs
their um
their youtube channels and they reached
out to us and asked us if we wanted to
make a short mini series for
um for their channel
um and so
they wanted to do it in the style of
you know like
the time we lit clint on fire with the
hollywood stuntmen and the time we threw
nico off the roof
and
we they kind of wanted to do like us
yeah with no prep we just pushed nico
they wanted to do like a
a stunt
expose that sort of like details and
features and explains and educates like
how
stunt performance is done so it's a
really cool opportunity um i'm hoping
that we make we're only doing four
episodes to start
but
the the dream is and the goal i think
with the show is that
we we create it so that it's
immediately
formattable to the actual netflix
platform
and then if it gets a bunch of views on
youtube then maybe they'll be like hey
let's just uh move these files over
you know and then and then they'll you
know
yeah drag and drop and then they come
back to us for another season you know
uh but ideally
for
the platform uh yeah even if it's not
that's the idea
even if it's not that show yeah
huge thanks to today's sponsor manscape
for always coming through on the podcast
now if you don't know manscape makes
some of the best hair and body trimming
tools and other body grooming and care
products on the market and one of them
the best one is their signature
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer this is the fourth
generation of their magnificent trimmers
but this isn't just any trimmer okay
this is the ultimate groin and body
trimmer it focuses on intelligent
functionality and it has an incredibly
comfortable grooming experience it also
comes with a 4000k led light so you can
see in those hard-to-reach places and it
also has advanced skin safe technology
on the blades which makes it a lot less
likely that you're going to be nicking
and cutting yourself down in those
sensitive areas the lawnmower also has
wireless charging and it gives you
different guard lengths so that you can
you know maybe you want to get fancy and
get artistic down there i don't know go
ahead so if you want to be one of the
millions of men who use manscaped as
their trusted product for their growing
and body hair trimming click the link in
the description below or go to
manscape.com and use the promo code
corridor cast to get 20 off plus free
shipping that's manscape.com using the
code cord or cast to get 20 off plus
free shipping huge thanks to them for
sponsoring and now let's get back to the
podcast
i think um
what we hope
is that
just expanding on what you just said is
that they will
realize oh people like behind the scenes
content is really good content and like
we're filling that void currently on
youtube
but there's like no behind the scenes
streaming shows
at all no there's no content about any
of the like thousands of ips that
netflix is cranking out there's no
content about it like how it's made
disney disney did release one on disney
plus called assembled
how they made um freaking whatever the
last i mean you're totally right disney
has actually been all right about
releasing content around like their
biggest things i mean like you know
mandalorian has some of the best behind
the scenes out there but that's because
mandalorian was really just the outcome
of all of ilms r d into stagecraft
it was you know a 200 million dollar
stage
that was uh
used for free by the mandalorian
production yeah so but i mean the thing
is like
a 200 million dollar stage is one thing
but like there's so much cool stuff that
goes on on your most basic sets that's
like you can make content out of
absolutely so that's where we come in i
think um
no i wholeheartedly agree because you
know back in the day especially when we
were growing up and in school and
whatnot we had dvds and dvds had special
features oh yeah those are the best
sometimes if you're lucky it was a
second disc dude
yeah brother there were like 40 hours of
behind the scenes so as a kid uh my
family and i would do these month-long
road trips every summer
and my dad would literally take an
entire month off from work and we had uh
you know an rv
uh or sorry a trailer and a truck and we
would drive like from where i grew up in
louisiana all the way up to like maine
and back or all the way up to like
oregon and canada and back and just
spend an entire month just doing that
and so i spent a lot of time in the back
of a car and just sitting there staring
out at the at the wilds right and so you
had the dvd with you and you just looked
at it
so many times yeah i just i got the dvd
and i just i remember if there was
if there was two discs you had more to
look at
yeah that makes sense yeah no like we
ended up getting one of those uh tvs
that we could put on like the center
console between the two front uh
uh seats
and i had
was it a dvd player or was it a
playstation one i can't remember
i couldn't remember no it wasn't a ps1
because i couldn't play dvds i think we
just had a little dvd player anyway
point being
uh we my sister and i watched the
entirety of the extended edition
behind the scenes
discs like each each
volume had like eight discs or something
like that and
it was just like the most wonderful
treasure trove of filmmaking knowledge
of all time it's like magic it's like
watching magicians and
when i was a 10 year old it just felt
like another world dude right i was like
what there's people who get to do this
yeah because they make chain mail
yeah
says the guy who like bumped into clint
eastwood at his dad's work this little
company called industrial light and
magic
bro
dude come on dude
i love how you describe that though you
bumped into this like lamp post of a
person you're like oh yeah and you just
went on your day and your dad was like
do you know who that was he's like dude
because this dirty hairy dude i'm like
who's that
does he make chainmail
no son
yeah
yeah
lord of the rings had he been making
chain mail you would have recognized i
would have actually given them the time
of day i was like yeah i've been
watching the extended editions with
daniel lately where he's in right now i
was supposed to come to the two towers
one and i couldn't i'm so devastated i
oh we got the return of the king those
are the best
i was super young and i would sneak down
before any of my family was awake at
like six in the morning and i would
watch the extended editions like it
would take me like four to five days to
finish one because people would wake up
and it would ruin my buzz
but uh that's how much you're all about
watching the extended editions in
secrecy legit i get it before anyone
else and just like someone said you
close your laptop
like oh what are you looking at what are
you looking at like nothing i saw you
know it's like you open was like lord of
the rings
[Laughter]
how long are the extended cuts
no they're like so the first one added
like 30 minutes of stuff i think the
second one added like 45 i think it's a
bit more and then the third one added
something like an hour and 15.
the third movie is something like four
and a half hours long yeah with the
experience but for each of them set
aside like four hours of pee breaks yeah
like just set that aside
i mean the first two movies each come on
yeah
why not just turn them into like many
movies
because streaming wasn't a thing back
then
oh that's true and the theatrical cut
was it was like it was a thing
it was a theatrical movie
designed for theaters as one single
story
but the other scenes that they cut out
for pacing and whatnot they they found
the middle ground like let's just
include them
in the extended editions to sell more
copies
sit there for can you really sit there
for longer than three hours though
yeah i've done it twice in the last
month it's ecstasy
i don't know about that i would say they
they made the hobbit into multiple
movies and that didn't work out yeah
actually that's best yeah some point to
your answer there yeah
so the hobbit was three movies that
should have been less than two gosh yeah
you know
at least one and then an episode of a
series one episode
like i'm saying it could have been one
or two yeah it would have totally worked
as one i also think it totally would
have worked as two sure three it didn't
work
all right
maria
yeah
yeah i remember the days of the trilogy
that was a
very common trilogy
i remember the days of the trilogy but
like
so i wonder with this new lord learning
show coming out is it going to be hour
long episodes half hour long because
like honestly if they're giving us
half-hour episodes i'm not gonna feel
full um that's so true my tummy is gonna
be left wanting more contour
i hope that i don't know that but i'm
still like confident
i hope they don't do so we were just
talking about this earlier actually
netflix i feel like they're pacing of
their content well not just netflix okay
it's like all the streaming platforms
they they speed through everything like
theatrical films used to take their time
like more character development there's
still structure and tight writing but
like i feel like when i watch a lot of
netflix stuff they're really trying to
like
just get through the story so fast
because i think it's like the youtube
thing that we contend with which is like
people can click away in a theater
people are there and they're in for it
and they're enjoying it they've got good
sound but like when people are watching
netflix or i'm just saying netflix
because it's just like streaming you
know it's like kleenex
when people are watching streaming it's
like you have
all the distractions like
usually when i'm watching streaming i go
on my phone and i don't even realize
that
there's real data on the plot
yeah there's real data on uh
like how
long they somebody will be
basically how likely will somebody be to
watch the entire show yeah and and at
what point
and so that's why like the first three
episodes especially of traditional seri
like of streaming series is like
usually way too much happening
because they're trying to they're trying
to get you hooked yeah on that so that
you can stick around for what happens
but
yeah i don't know it's it's almost like
a
problem of their own success you know
like yeah they they almost everything
that's on netflix now is netflix
original now
um
and you know there's a couple reasons
for why that is one of the reasons is
because a lot of the traditional
industry has literally moved over
to streaming and so there's just not as
many movies being made
in the traditional space anymore
um
but another reason is that you know they
just started making more of their own
shows
um and so there's literally the like i
don't even know what's on there anymore
who knows who knows what's going on so
much how many titles do they have nobody
knows yeah yeah
it's just crazy it didn't it didn't used
to be like that and i'm not saying i'm
not being like one of those people who's
like back in the day i'm just saying
like
there used to be a limited amount of
content available on netflix i remember
when that was and when they came out
with a netflix original it was
significant and it was very much like
the traditional other mediums or the
other shows and movies that were on
there
as as time has gone by and they've moved
away from that model so has the content
it's moved into more like
some something between a youtube show
and a tv show
i just yeah
i hope that the amazon lord of the rings
thing like we all do i think we're all
like cautiously excited about it
that's a good way to describe it it's
like i want it to be good yeah i always
wanted to like it dean was hating on it
from the
we're only hating on it to like guard
ourselves emotionally i said
i was reading online so yeah i mean
you're totally right i was reading
online uh about the lord of the rings
fandom and they're saying that basically
there is no other fandom that would
prefer
their stuff to just not be made
um interesting
like yeah
someone dug up comments and reviews
preceding the first lord of the rings
movie we're talking like
october 20 201 2001
and and it was all these people like
they they'd like set pictures were
leaked and like some some rumors about
changes that were made from the book to
the movie and people were outraged like
how dare they
do this to their
you know their favorite thing and
they're gonna boycott it or they're
gonna specifically pirate it to you know
stick it to the man
and now it's like all those same people
were like it's the best
trilogy ever made yeah i think you got
to give it a chance regardless yeah you
know the opening like so i did watch the
trailer there were some effects in there
that seemed a little unpolished but i
i've tried to make a rule to never
really
harsh on
the effects that are in trailers because
they're usually unfinished but
the shot of the giant waterfall and then
galadriel like climbing i was just like
oh my god that's amazing i was so
excited about it looks cool i i was like
i'm on board with this i don't know what
they're doing but the synopsis that i've
heard so far it's about like how the the
rings of power were like created and
like their implications i'm like i am on
board with that story
100 didn't they drop like a billion on
it
a half a billion i have a billion i'm
way over there an absurd amount of money
so they're going to be hour-long
episodes so we're
you know be clear here we don't know the
sort of breakdown of that kind of budget
same reason why we don't well okay
when i say breakdown we don't know how
much infrastructure they're building for
the future seasons of
ring of power whatever the show's called
yeah lord of the rings right um you know
same thing for mandalorian in the in the
stagecraft set it was a 200 million
dollar set that could have easily been
part of the 65 million dollar budget
for
lord of the rings for the show
lord of the rings show
mm-hmm
yeah uh okay
[Laughter]
just calculated yeah
for a second because it's just like
thinking of all the possibilities
yeah
what i'm trying to say is that the
mandalorian was able to get away with
having such extreme production value
because disney was able to write off
the production asset of the stagecraft
volume right as r d cost because disney
owns ilm ilm you know did the stagecraft
thing and so
the mandalorian was able to have a
healthy budget
for everything else by being able to
utilize that and so what i'm saying with
lord of the rings is that we don't know
how much infrastructure amazon's
building
that
yeah they're spilling they're spending
this much money on this first season
lord of the rings but maybe the next
season will be like a third of the cost
because
they've already laid the groundwork
imagine the points you'd get if you put
all of that on a credit card
if you put 460 mil on a credit card
you'd be chilling for a while i don't
know if that's how it works
you'd probably be better off if you put
that in an interest bearing okay that's
fair i mean
anything else yeah
i don't think jordan's making it yeah um
look
that's that's cray cray okay i
understand what you're saying ren but
that's cray cray and it's no wonder that
so many people from
traditional media have moved over
to streaming because
like that's what the budget is that's
that's like more than
well yeah
that's also a rare budget it's a
uh record-breaking budget most of the
time streaming you're looking at
severely reduced budgets
well or even like big netflix movies
yes
oh sorry i'm sorry
the whole time he's trying to make a
point it'd be a real shame if you
tripped and fell down these stairs
yes and no one of the reasons why
budgets are so cheap on streaming
platforms is because they get made
before they get licensed
okay yeah yeah and the money's not
directly coming from
this the studio it's more of a gamble
than i am
yeah but you're you're not wrong budgets
are sometimes cheaper but it is i guess
what i'm trying to say is it's a sign of
the times like
five years ago eight years ago
rhett doing a project for amazon or
netflix was still considered to be like
um you know look down even even like
even like four years ago
it was still considered to be like a
second tier not not where the truest
form of artistic enterprise is occurring
at
but now clearly like that threshold is
being crossed
and and that that started being crossed
when it went from movies to tv shows in
general like you know 10 15 years ago
when we started seeing quality shows
coming out on yo
movies when movies were surpassed like
the fame of tv show
people
surf started to surpass
and and the shows themselves started to
surpass like traditional doing tv was
also looked down on in general for a
long time it was like oh you're going
back to tv now that you've made it to
movies that's a shame but now it's like
oh man dude he's trying to get a creepy
contract kid good for him i mean when he
shows like a full feature for the day
but now he's doing freaking
10 10 episode season shows legit that's
like five films yeah straight up
it is nice to see that it is nice to see
that
the the medium of like
storytelling
has not gone by the wayside with the
demise
of traditional movies
like it's it's i am seeing very clearly
it's being picked back up by streaming
and yeah that's really cool to see
because for a while there that was
that was in question it was like well
is any is any of this
gonna be the same or or better
um now that comes with its own problems
right like in this now in the digital
streaming system you your things are
like created by producers more
than they're created by auteurs
but
you know
you definitely feel it and i i think
where you feel that is like back to the
pacing thing and like the character
development thing like
i feel like a lot of movies i watch on
streaming services that are originals
right now at least are
just very by the book script formats
where you can tell the ideas like you're
saying came from producers or they came
from actors who wanted to green light a
project their own
and were in as producers
because usually most of these originals
have like one actor attached to start
star power which is like a thing in
blockbusters too for sure but like
yeah you can tell like there isn't that
like
super dialed in on tour thing and
they're really like
controlling the the speed of the
storytelling but
yeah no i mean you're right for all i
[ __ ] a lot about like
movies
there's no original movies and stuff but
it's really nice to be able to ha like
really i mean yeah just look at
manchester by the sea just like
manchester united
can you please just change the subject
to a lighter subject like masks okay
yeah um
be way easier
it's like having having three seasons
which is what like freaking like 30
hours sometimes to explore story is like
it's a lot yeah it's pretty awesome you
know i wonder though like the reason why
the movies of our childhood and you know
before that like you know the 80s
kind of in the 90s being like
pretty much the epitome of the
traditional
motion picture format foggies yeah well
that that i i think that will happen
eventually with streaming like i don't
think it's i don't think it's anywhere
close
to what its true
like final form will be artistically i i
think it's just
just getting going
and and i think in time like there will
be people who come along
who like have that sort of authorial
sway over like entire shows
um it's just i think that the the medium
hasn't
like as an economic exercise like it
hasn't
come into its own yet you know and so i
think it's being
right now it's all by the book because
it's like look we don't know nobody's
we're in new territory but i think in
another like 10 years especially another
like 20 years when these platforms
really like solidify and and become the
way
of distribution
i think that'll start to happen
oh for sure i thought power to the dog
was a good example of that it was very
like authority you know it was like kind
of indie but like storytelling was
really good took its time
it felt like a normal movie check it out
it's really it's really good it's a
netflix yeah um
you know
i thought it was well acted and well
directed but anyway lord of the rings i
hope lord of the rings can be that for
us i hope it can bring the medium fully
fully to that yeah cinematic i don't
know which is that you only get our vibe
that you got from the original you know
yeah it's just gonna drop as an nft
though so you're gonna
dude the original lord of the rings was
like
like we're all a family right and he was
like lord of the rings was like our
father who taught us all about how to
appreciate cinema thanks to how to be
inspired and
like really do it he was a hard worker
you know wasn't always the prettiest but
the hard work he was a good man and then
our mom dumped like he died and like our
mom got like remarried like to like this
like hobbit stepped down
he's rich and he was flashy he drove a
ferrari but he really
and then our mom like dumped him and
like disappeared for like like 10 years
and then like
had a sex change and turned into jeff
bezos yeah and and that was remarrying
mom jeff is that yeah and he's just
going to space and flies down from space
and lands in your driveway that's right
what a metaphor at this point you really
you've got a family of your own you
don't know what to expect you're trying
to explain to the children that it was
your that it's their grandmother but now
it's their grandfather the whole thing
is just very confusing and awkward and
you just hope it goes over well yeah and
you want you want to accept the new step
dad or whoever this person is into your
family you know
come on lord of the rings i think i
think the healthy move is thanksgiving
you set the bar as low as possible
emotionally
all of my best experiences in film and
in shows has been when i have an
incredibly low or no bar
setting anything above mediocre you're
gonna be let down
it's like hey this is my third
thanksgiving and you still are asking me
what my name is like
you know and you're like look i set the
bar really low for you cause i didn't
think you'd be coming back
you
know i mean when you say you're gonna go
to 7-eleven to pick up cigarettes we all
know what that means
yeah we knew you weren't coming back
i'm going to make another lord of the
rings yeah i'm never going to call this
series dad
but i might have room in my heart for a
little bit of love we'll see yeah yeah
maybe like maybe like first name basis
like hey dan you're hey daniel yeah well
then you know i'll hang out with you
instead of like mr like mr
miyagi yeah
[Laughter]
dan wants to take the kids to the
playground for like two hours they'll
have fun it'll be fine just you know me
trust me yeah i mean he's got he's got
to earn that he's got to earn that he's
got her i'm talking like after the first
couple episodes you know then maybe
you know
we'll see
all right i'm gonna leave that review on
the series after the first episode if i
don't like it i'm just going to say real
dad yeah i'm going to say thanks for
nothing mr miyagi and that'll be my
review one star
oh man
you know what
guys maybe we should get everyone on the
podcast to go over there and comment
thanks for answering this
only if it's bad though oh yeah we'll
see we'll see i hope to not see any of
those comments oh me too in theater i
hope to see that i i i hope we don't see
any of them because the show's good but
if the show is bad i i hope we see all
of them just caked with them well the
actual trailer itself is caked with the
same comment i don't know if you saw but
literally
no the trailer for lord of the rings
every single comment is the same quote
from jrr told it's like a really salty
quote yeah but like evil cannot create
anything new it can just distort what
already exists sorry for butchering it
everybody but that's the gist of it yeah
that's the gist of it it's like amazon
being the evil can't create anything new
they can just distort what already
exists and it was every comment it was
crazy wow i've if it's every comment
that sounds like a bot in multiple
languages um
i've not
paid any attention to feedback on on
that show i don't even have any idea
what people think of it mm-hmm okay all
i know is
just just to piggyback on that that com
that that token comment
is
amazon evil
oh
[Music]
i mean
inherently for real though i don't yeah
so i inherently i'd have to say no i
have to say no it's not inherently evil
but
yeah i think i think given
given
it's
like it's just so big
you know it's like but does that make it
evil
like no i've heard a lot of bad things
about thoroughly but how they handle
their workers it's
you know how they used to put like you
know how they used to put like ornate
crown molding in houses like in the
turn of the 20th century and by the time
the like 1940s and 50s rolled around
like we were done with that oh yeah and
the reason was because it was too
expensive to do that in every single
house
and in order to build houses and provide
enough houses for the demand for housing
you just you had to build the damn
houses
you know but it's the same thing
happening like the art of the crown
molding like i want everyone to have a
house just as much as the next person i
want everyone to get their chinese goods
and etc just as much as the next person
right get your amazon goods
but
there's that like there's that little
loss of soul
you know when when like
the amazon package shows up and you're
like
yeah
maybe you guys don't feel that way i
definitely feel i'm like [ __ ] dude i
needed a usb cable and i got it in a day
i've never had more toothbrushes okay
yes so that's good like okay like i need
batteries and a usb cable
and like
some you know toilet paper okay you know
i get like i get that i get that but
like
obviously those are like the most
commonly sold items on amazon but that's
obviously not all they sell
they sell it's all about convenience i
don't know man yeah i don't know enough
about it but
it's convenience
but i think convenience can be unhealthy
i agree yeah i guess you could call it
evil i think like if things are too too
convenient then like our reason for
living goes away like if you really want
to do something
you're really wondering
no i mean like you know like we we have
evolved with struggle and we yeah we
need like some sort of challenge in life
to
feel yeah
so if i guess if you could say like hey
if i can just order everything on amazon
in a day what's the point of anything
well i will say i started driving amazon
two days shipping on happiness yes
i started driving when when the maps
thing started the garmin maps you know
the little navigation units started
coming out and that was the exact same
time i started driving
and so i never had to learn my streets
i think it was 30 i'm 30.
yeah we did it we made it wait you're 30
on the dot 30 flat
same right down the line we're both very
flexible yeah i remember when we first
met you thought i was younger than you i
did yeah and you started talking about
like oh yeah being 30 it's a
it's it's a trip you're gonna you got
something to look forward to like i've
been 30 for three years
[Laughter]
the most common
response i get from meeting people in
real life people who know how i am from
the show and or you know youtube
most often the first thing they say is
wow you're taller than i expected yeah
that was my first thought universally
and i don't know why that is
one of the top comments on the the
freaking attack on titan video too right
i literally call out my height and
everyone's like i'm more blown away by
that than anything
you should do vfx artist explains his
hiking
i thought you were five foot four and 25
years old
dude i guess i've just got young short
guy energy
it's good energy i mean yeah i mean
there's worse energies you know it's
very youthful
yeah i was i was more surprised about
the height though when i met you
wait so go on about the maps though
jordan i want to get yeah
um yeah so so i had those at my disposal
immediately and i've lived in you know
the la area for almost my whole life
lived in luxury and i don't know where
anywhere is
i don't know literally and i should i
should i absolutely should i know it's
bad i don't know this i just literally
i'll enter it in my phone i will enter
it in the map it will take me there i
won't pay attention it took me longer
than i care to admit to learn how to get
here from my house well
yeah what about now so this is not
exactly what i this is what i mean this
is what i mean literally where am i
where am i this is the essence of what
i'm saying
let's remove that word from the
conversation but like
that's obviously got a ton of utility
right
like absolute ability to just punch in
an address and like show up where it's
at
but
when you re but like
you remember those very basic tools
now all of a sudden without the tools
you are ineffective as a navigator yeah
and it's like
maybe you don't want either you know
maybe yeah it is like a weird i think
you want to balance i mean yeah there's
like a thing you know
historians often say that like once once
a society gets too comfortable that's
when the decline
quote decline starts just like you know
in rome like you know you had these
periods of peace
and then you'd have horrible events
where like everyone got too comfortable
and they forgot how to like fight for
survival essentially so i mean i don't
know if that
i don't think that's exactly where we
are but like there's definitely like we
got it good like i mean yeah i think we
are we're living like
all this country
i think that's exactly where we are okay
thank you jake i'm with you dude that's
fine i
i kind of agree in some respects i'm
there that's for sure i actually didn't
hear you said jake oh he said he thinks
i think i think we i think we're
experiencing a little societal decline
because of all the creep creature
comforts that we have access to and
their immediacy and their the the
incredibly low cost at which they are
available well i think that is true a
little bit if you want to go there i
think that we are
in in that mindset so much so that small
inconveniences
uh are really pissing us off and and
making us feel like we're having our
rights infringe like oh i have to wear a
mask it's my right so my happiness it's
like [ __ ] you don't have to go
yeah you can order a [ __ ] double a
battery on amazon out of there in like
two hours there's a lot of that specific
topics
it sucks man it [ __ ] sucks i i
totally agree with you nick but that
isn't necessarily like an apples to
apples
i am getting furious about there is
nothing more in life that i hate
more
than slow internet
that's fair
this is a good example this is a great
example
you know what do you say it's worse than
no internet yeah
slow internet is worse than knowing they
did not have the internet at all no i'm
like does that look like that
it's like a mental switch you know if i
know i'm not gonna have any internet i'm
like all right
i know that i can like do other things i
don't have to expect that i can put on a
youtube video and it'll work i know that
it won't instead of putting it on being
like it's buffering all the time is that
just because you grew up in a time where
you didn't have access to the internet
all the time though because now think
about if you grew up
constant access to the internet would
having slow access to the internet
constantly feel like how you're saying
you know
i don't know because you you you grew up
you grew up without constant access to
the internet yeah of course yeah right
like all millennials dude
but
they feel so old um
yeah like no no like on this topic i
specifically have a memory and this is
gonna be one of those things that like
if i have grandkids they're gonna be
like grandpa you're old as [ __ ]
my dad i remember this it's a vivid
memory of my childhood my dad sat me
down he's like son i'm gonna teach you
what the internet is there's this new
thing called the internet and our
internet wasn't good enough for him to
show me on the internet he had to draw
out a map of the internet like he drove
like a little diagram and like this page
connects to this page but like we didn't
have the internet so you can show me it
was like this abstract concept how
confusing was that for you i was just
like oh that's cool yeah can i go play
dude my fifth grade band teacher told me
what google was um
yeah thanks mr miyagi he was really
pissed that like some of the people
were not good at playing music and so he
marched all of us to the library went to
www.google.com and said look at this
magical thing here type in whatever you
want and stuff just appears it's funny
that you say that because that's when
people still typed in the w's
yeah that's how you know it's old when
people were putting the wwe
[Laughter]
yeah like think about if you're coming
you're coming up with this okay imagine
it's the 1980s you're coming up with
this abstract
manifestation of this idea and you're
like okay like
it's it's not in our world currently but
maybe one day the world will have it be
integrated into all their things so
we're but we're going to call it like
this something other like the world wide
web
yeah you know
rather than like oh you need an internet
connection to do this with this device
which is how it is now it's so
integrated it's just like considered
so basic but thanks for that information
i need to have some words with my dad
because he really dropped the ball in
his presentation
i'm missing crucial information
and i'm not happy about it i also love
that he illustrated the point as like an
actual like visual classic dad like he
always draws i mean
he was an illustrator in some ways yeah
and he probably made that stuff look
good but um
no
like oh another thing netflix is gonna
be like we're gonna be like yeah we had
to select the movie and they'd mail it i
loved that though dude i loved that that
was so exciting it was like
legit
it was great it was like so exciting
when that thing would arrive you know
and then you'd run outside movies you'd
open them up the little get the little
disc
open we had that for
i got it and kept it for a lot longer
than most people did i still had disc
rentals in like freaking 20
16. dude 2017. it's amazing i finally
canceled every movie like that was the
thing that was
better
no i did it was like you know it wasn't
about i got you know i was really into
like blue rays at the time and i just
looking at him yeah again it was just
like bringing it back to my dad's new
car just like looking at the cover of
the disc
they're so shiny when they hit that sun
you uh you hit a sore spot with me on
blu-rays i bought into hd dvds oh no
i picked wrong y'all hdd i had i bought
an hd dvd player with the money that i
made from like an acting thing that i
did
and i bought three hd dvds
and that's all the hdtvs i ever got to
buy because then they immediately
stopped which i think i got 300 okay i
got hd dvd
magic
you mean like 1080 dvd
i don't remember
it was the name for the high definition
dvds that were coming out it was blu-ray
is the format that ended up winning the
format it was a real xbox playstation
thing but it lasted about six weeks
except and we lost
down in flames i thought dvd that's name
brand recognition like we're on a vlog
at the moon y'all
[Laughter]
oh yeah i remember these i remember
these it's fun because there's an extra
d in there hd dvd
sounds like you caught a bad case of the
hd dvi
that's probably why they didn't win just
the branding oh they thought it was a
disease
because what was the blu-ray it sounds
like it's a laser that's coming from the
internet
hd dvd sounds like it's some sort of
venereal disease i like the sound of
that yeah do you guys remember laserdisc
oh gosh that one really lost yeah well
that was more just because it was like
expensive and a little much imagine like
dvds that look like vinyl records that's
how big they were
and you would still have to take it out
and flip it over to get the rest of the
movie no laser just no you didn't yeah
did you actually yeah i had it i
i had a friend who had it and it was
like that was
jake it just got transported
i did just get transported are you
looking laser disc
first released december 11th
1978
damn oh wow ahead of its time though
for sure optical disk storage this is
the original disk that's why the that's
where the contact that's where this is
the first stitch that's why the cd was
the compact disc
[Laughter]
sorry
[Laughter]
let's find out romulus romulus cd rom cd
from this cd rom this is like is it an
acronym or is it uh
shorthand read only memory
oh
god i miss the floppy disks they say you
learn something new every day and they
weren't as floppy as advertised i'll say
that they were rigid they were pretty
dangerous this is a perfect example of
your www thing imagine if cd-rom became
so integrated into society that it was
just like
what they just were like
rant read-only memory of course it's
read-only memory
wait
what's dvd stand for
digital video
devices digital videos
disk okay i was close the second disk
digital video digital no you're both
wrong
digital video disc or
digital versatile disk
versatile
it can be played in who's the rebel with
the versatility in the dvd market wow
who's the rebel disrupting the disc
market
all those all those advancements though
were all so exciting in their own right
like i remember when we got our first
computer in the house and i switched
over from n64 gaming to computer gaming
i think that was the jump i made
and i got rome total war i don't know if
you guys ever played wrong totally i
still play rome totally yeah legit
i'm playing that tonight dude
are you familiar with what it is yeah
yeah for anyone out there who doesn't
know it's like a simulation of war like
these massive armies fight and it's
fantastic and i saw that i saw the
trailer and i bought the disc and i put
it in and i was so excited and i'm not
joking the opening video the video yeah
i got like one frame per second oh yeah
on my computer cinematics i remember
like an elephant and then the elephant
was gone and there were people that's
how big of the jump it was wow
i was devastated yeah i i think i went
immediately back to donkey kong six
years
yeah heartbreaking the total war games
are like my favorite games and they put
a depressing i'm embarrassed to say how
many hours i've put into all the
companies probably like a year of my
life like i'm actually 29. i had no idea
about this no i play them all i love
them
medieval total war won wow got me into
history like it got my interest in
history and i think
i'm so thankful to like wow can i shake
your hand of assembly
what can i shake your hand yeah of
course i also love rome total war and
all the total wars you know i didn't
know that about you jordan like it's
exciting moment you just like you're
just speaking of this
okay i've heard of the game before
you're you're not at the same level now
but it's like the same thing right it's
like
no but um dude that's awesome i i have
such fond memories of of like early pc
gaming on medieval because
best game ever hmm
best
it was like a first gameplay shooter but
you were
in a ship
and you're in space and mining asteroids
and you're destroying all the bots that
have gone rogue but it was like six
degree freedom you could like rotate and
so it was like you had all these levels
that it wasn't just like there was no
gravity so the game design the level
design was really interesting mm-hmm
because you could actually like do all
types of like twisting around oh sorry
what year was that it was like 95
95 great year for gaming
wait expand on that please
yeah i can't
jake what were you saying a moment ago
listen i i just you guys all this
reminiscing got me down a little
googling rabbit hole here which also to
point out google googling is now a verb
in our lives
weird uh yeah i was just over here duck
duck going down your kids
know like are your kids just like saying
i'm gonna google this google that like
do they appreciate what that even comes
from what are the reasons um i don't
know if they use that word yet i i
haven't heard them yet
to google something
dude kids are gonna grow up thinking
google's always been a thing amazon's
always been a thing like i'm telling you
right now if i could change one thing
about human history well i'll say
there's not one thing about human
history but i could change something
about human history
i would have had ask jeeves win
the race of search engines because
was so nice like that just rolls off the
top
that's cheese
yeah dude like that's so have you ever
heard of mass juice no i haven't oh okay
okay i wasn't sure
i think i used it sgg is for translating
stuff because it was able to do like
language translations before google did
jeeves was a talented i asked all of
life's hardest questions internet
butler's go he was he was the best he's
smart
let's see what he has i miss him
what happened to jesus
that they got bought by yahoo yeah and
then y'all who took them out to the barn
and yeah
we're gonna buy this whole little cheese
guys
okay
someone's gotta buy a plot of
and put a little jeeves tombstone on
their planet
here's what happened
you ready
i got my enemies
in late 2010
facing insurmountable competition from
more popular search engines like google
ask jeeves outsourced its web search
technology and return to its roots as a
question and answer site
says
let's find out what do you want to know
guys they took the jeeves just ask jesus
yeah who took the tea who took jesus
out to the barn
it's still the cold case
let's see what it's got on this one
he said he was going out for sure he
said the same thing
who killed
who killed jeeves
we need answers
i'll be more direct yeah
who killed jeeves
this is going in weird places
uh still not not giving me any answers
of course kind of what i expected yeah
yeah
what they're all here let's let's see
the ultimate question
what is ask
wait what if it gives me no results on
this question zero results found
what is ask jeeves
jeeves ask steve's asked it's quick and
easy to protect jesus
it gives me no answers what ha wow wait
what
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait the
g's ever exist what happened to ask
jeeves tell me now ask please
what do you say it gives me no answer
we're still going to go cover up dude
yep this is a cover okay the only thing
it does is wait because i think it's
written by the victors dude they turned
jeeves out to you
they buried them dude they burnt all
over to the vanquished nick yep thank
god
to the vanquish the vancouver went out
for jeeves tonight
okay if i google this
what happened to ask jeeves
see how deep this rabbit hole goes yeah
let's see how deep the conspiracy goes
yeah it gives me top results all related
to the death of ask jeeves if i if i
search
what happened to ask jeeves on ask.com
um
[Laughter]
sorry germans oh yeah oh man listen
we've all we've all had our problems
over the years
um wow including ask jeeves we've all
stumbled into belgium a couple times
oh no german's lovely people love people
you guys uh you guys hey belgians you
guys know your way to the maginot line
i'm trying to get somewhere
belgians do exist
we got to stop anger in the europeans so
manchester by the sea
back to the hard topics manchester by
the sea is it worth watching
answers next time oh man
i don't know what a tease okay wait a
second before i was gonna before i was
gonna do this before i went down the
rabbit hole of ask jeeves there was one
more thing i wanted to talk about
early 2000s forgotten technologies such
as
the gigapet did you guys know people oh
my goodness
oh yeah
well manslaughter and remember remember
how controversial it was when kids were
like getting depressed let me just
google this one oh yeah yeah dude get in
depression remember that that was the
first like like
freaking buzzfeed
like millennials are like getting
depressed because they can't buy houses
when like articles was about kids
getting sad because their tamagotchis
died and they'd gone yeah depression oh
wow no i got i was like when i first i
accidentally scared
i accidentally killed my my
it was a gigapad it wasn't a time i got
you my sister at a time i got cheated i
accidentally killed it by scolding it
too much oh man and it was like actually
traumatizing you
we were camping at the time and he just
started making fun of me and i just like
it was it was a i remember this day okay
that's awful yeah it's hilarious
outside of the actual traumatizing
memories of it but
oh my gosh
2011 new york times sorry not 2011. 1997
new york times article
tamagotchi
love it feed it
mourn it
a dog may be a man's best friend but a
virtual pet can be a child's worst
nightmare children who are nurturing the
tiny tamagotchi cyber pet a popular
japanese digital toy
are discovering that virtual death can
be nearly as traumatic as the real thing
wow
it's moving
christine glickman her son keith nine
cried hysterically and went crazy in
quotes when his tamagotchi expired
extremely sad and depressed over the
demise of her cyber pet
this is
that's wild dude i'm like not gonna lie
i'm low-key kind of getting a little
like upset remembering my gigapay yeah
well this is its name i forget his name
he was a little alien dude
yeah dude
the whole thing about that though is
that like it's 100 reasonable because
it's just about loss the idea of loss
does it the context is irrelevant
loss is something that we can all
understand and so it's unfortunate when
people are like
it's just a girl pet yeah wilson and
castor maybe
exactly wilson
maybe somebody who gets so upset about
that though needs to experience like
some more context with loss and if
that's their first experience with loss
then obviously it can be a little yeah i
mean there's a scale there
that's necessary
like you know
and not being able to joke about kids
experiencing trauma from losing a
tamagotchi come
it's like hey you love this guy for like
a week and then it dies yeah now you
know
go to your room dude yeah i think it's
valid to to point out like how you know
the loss of that is very different than
say like the loss of like a family
member or something like that but
it's still real to that person and
i guess what i'm saying is like some of
those reactions i've seen in the past
pretend like that loss isn't real
and that's my problem well when you're a
kid you don't have the ability to
discern what is alive and what isn't i
thought my stuffed animals were alive
when i was a kid
yeah one of them got beheaded i'd be
devastated yeah hypothetically
hypothetically
no it's true i mean dude
pets for sure i mean but obviously
there's some media embellishing maybe
that goes on to stir up and trump up
fear and like
you know that article i think is a
perfect example no one no one
10 how many years later is it 15 years
later is it going to be
longer than that
little did they know that 25 years later
stabbing their parents because they took
away fortnite you know on the xbox and
[ __ ] like
wait yeah did that happen
probably
a precursor to that
[Laughter]
all i know is that
it's gotten much worse
now every kid's addicted to video games
and uh they lose all the time so
and hence the conversation earlier about
the minor demises in our own culture
people are in familiar with dealing with
loss and when they lose their fortnight
they take it out on mom and dad
and that is
that
no i'm not saying that that's the truth
but
that's that's a sign of some creature
comforts going on where we need to we
need to take a step back and realize
okay people get serious goddamn
we're sorry somebody asked jeeves about
this please just saying like
like
take away all of it just to live in this
time i say this all the time but like
what i love about history is it just
makes me grateful it makes me so
grateful for everything
and just like hey we're born now yeah
that's great yeah
okay that's been around for like 100
years bro like we're honored educated
straight white people how lucky we have
gpu rendering oh ren don't put this on
our
header
i'm not trying to make your own noise
obviously there's a lot of nuances in
that statement but like in general like
we have so much like we can get fruit
let's not pretend like privilege only
belongs to straight white people ren
i was just saying i'm lucky to be that
way no man always be grateful we're so
lucky to be however you are no you're
like that's a
blessing to be however you are you
should be proud of however you look and
however you feel and all that stuff
i guess i should clarify that i'm lucky
to have privilege i'll put it that way
yeah for sure
we all are
and that doesn't that's not just
something that's that's not just
something that's owned by people that
look like us
everyone's got a little bit of it of
privilege and it's it's a good thing but
it does it does make some people weak
that's for sure yeah
i guess what i was
stating a gratitude for was like that
overall privilege that maybe you're
talking about it's like yeah there's
definitely different levels of privilege
depending on what subset of person you
were born as i suppose
so let's be grateful for that but also
just like
there's like a universal privilege of
just like having things to communicate
with yeah i don't know have cameras that
we can film awesome movies with exactly
i don't know hot water i'm just crazy
here's a here you want a hard hater nick
you you know about this julius caesar
wrote about this how the gauls used to
believe that
you know they one of their rituals
before they would go into battle was
they would they believed that if they
didn't sacrifice a life for every life
that they thought they were going to
take in battle that it would anger the
gods
and so they would they would gather up
criminals and if they ran out of
criminals you know
who whoever else they could get their
hands get over here jeeves get over here
they would they would they would create
these giant wicker
like burning men
like and they would put
people
in there they would fill them up with
people
and then light them on fire yeah
so that's that that there's that that
privilege
that's that's what i'm talking about
when it comes to like we all are
experiencing a privilege that is not a
time that we live in anymore
dude
that dude celtic culture oh man i wish i
wish more of that survived but that's a
whole other other topic
jake and i nerd out about history for oh
just like we have there's like so so
little because they didn't have a
written language so like all we have is
even more of the history
of like
gaul and
the traditions of burning people in
wicker
man that was a great i love wicker this
is a good time
their culture had other merits that
would be nice if they were preserved
obviously was it in scotland that we're
talking about like you could buy like a
square foot of land or something like
that you're coming forward
[Laughter]
to become
[Laughter]
doing a british accent in scotland oh
god
no they'll love that it's very actually
in context
oh man no british people yeah now we're
back full circle to george washington
yes we are we've come back um all right
there's so much to talk about it's a
little time
maybe we'll go on about uh
the wars of julius caesar and gaul on
the next podcast i don't know i would
love to
i've been reading all about julius
caesar
i bought i bought his writings
tell me more about listen to dan carlin
dude it's writings it's real interesting
man
um i just finished the african campaign
and it's
it's great let me tell you juba what a
guy
gripping is the right way to put it yeah
he's a newbie
he's a newbie king
yeah
are you if you guys are interested and
you want to listen to a great podcast
that's available for free this isn't a
promotion paid promotion anyway it is
definitely a promotion
but just because it's awesome dan carlin
the celtic holocaust uh about julius
caesar's campaigns in gaul
is a phenomenal five-hour
epic podcast where he dives into all the
different elements and inspired me to
buy
a couple books that he was using as
reference material um dude reading
julius caesar's books on that note is
that's
that's crazy though to think about like
obviously he embellished you know for
his own personal gain but like
we get to sit here
and read text
from this guy
who's like one of the most famous
dictators
tyrants you know generals
warriors
like heroes whatever you want to call
him
of all time
and it's like i can just buy i bought
his book on amazon
there you go that that ties it all
together it really does
produce the book on amazon
because he basically he's like for like
ten dollars
yeah and this is shipped to you for ten
dollars
seriously
like
it was like he had so much luck but also
just like somehow he was just brilliant
getting out of these super sticky
situations
like yeah and like some of the things he
was able to like survive
were are just like amazing over and over
again and then like it's just like his
daily his daily grind is just like oh
man damn i gotta like move the army over
and build a whole new camp
[ __ ] defeat maybe a whole army like did
he sound happy
yeah he's just like i'm julius caesar
i'm going to i don't think happy entered
into his thinking i think it was about
how ambitious
yeah ambitious all of those guys for
some reason like all of those guys like
pompey and caesar and like all the guys
around that time
it was like they knew
that their names
would
would go through history
and they they did everything they did
was to like further that yeah it's
really
really crazy
um to to contextualize in modern times
yeah
it's uh it's pretty cool to read
and then like yeah i mean dude
next podcast i'm sorry i could just i'm
going to keep talking unless you cut me
off so no yeah i think he's trying to
get into this on the next one yeah all
right
just come here i'm going to cut it off
i'm going to cut it off sorry if we uh
upset anyone talking about manchester by
the sea
i understand uh there's some tough
topics out there but you know what the
more you uh engage with those topics
with friends and family you know the
better off we'll all be exposed to i
watched the last duel
yes oh well i saw that
yeah you should watch i thought it was
on hbo
it's a good movie yeah
it's really good
affleck reminded me of that
netflix
yeah i mean when you need casey what was
it insurance
what time brett worked out with casey
affleck
yeah yeah why i used to work at the y
just
like a couple years ago
this is just the ymca in korea town and
like freaking casey affleck walks and
he's like hey can you help me live oh we
actually worked out with it yeah yeah
and then brett was just like yesterday
he faded down on this conversation yeah
we're just gonna disappear um so julius
caesar man
first and generics really had him pinned
and you know
double development of a you know he
built a fort around the fort that for so
long
built a camp
sorry i think it was
another roman army had a camp first and
generous comes in surrounds the camp
so what does julius caesar do that mad
like that's a campaign
american ghettos was on the hill
and caesar had surrounded him and he and
he called in a bunch of other horsemen
right okay caesar built a wall on the
inside and outside yeah yeah yeah
caesar found out that a three yes and a
two